Good morning, everyone.
Thank you for coming to this session on advances in glioblastoma research and
experimental therapies.
If you're here, you're already done the hardest part, which is finding the room.
So well done.
As you know, I'm sure many of you in the audience, I recognize many
faces, you're very familiar with the challenges of gliomas
and brain cancer in general. We're going to try to highlight
some of those challenges. They're a little bit different types of cancer than other
organs.
We're going to discuss how they're integrated with the central nervous system
parenchyma, how they're forming interconnected network.
We're going to discuss some of the unique features of the microenvironment, and
then also discuss some of the unique aspects of their molecular
heterogeneity. So to cover all these aspects, we have four speakers, and
our first one is Varun Venkataramani from Heidelberg University,
who will be discussing about
integration of glioblastoma into neural network.
Yes. Thank you so much, Mario, and
I want to thank you and all the organizers for giving me the opportunity here to
talk here today about our research on brain tumor networks, as
well as neural mechanisms that drive glioblastoma.
I have no disclosures. And I want to start off by
basically a historic slide,
which I got from Nick Castro from MGH,
highlighting basically the challenges of glioblastoma, because I was always under
the impression that we have been bad at treating glioblastoma in
the last three to four decades,
when learning that we've actually been bad at treating this disease
for more than 100 years here, when it was still called
with a different name, spongioblastoma multiforme, and when you look at the
survival times,
nothing much has really changed in these 100 years.
So what makes these brain tumors so incurable from our points of view?
So basically,
these tumors are a whole brain disease.
You see here an autopsy section of a patient with an IDH mutant
astrocytoma. And you see basically in the brown color here, the main
tumor mass
and where all these black dots indicate where you can find tumor cells
throughout the entire brain, which makes it clear that you cannot surgically
resect the entire tumor.
The remaining parts are resistant towards standard of care treatment
with chemo and radiotherapy,
and basically no targeted therapy has been really successful in the
last decades.
So what we think is that we have to really rethink also how we
study tumors in the brain, because simply
taking treatments from tumors outside the brain and applying them for
brain tumors has not worked out. So we need to understand tumors in their
microenvironment.
And when really studying these tumors in their
intricate communication with the central nervous
system, what you find is that these tumor cells are basically not
alone, but that they're really communicating with the central nervous system.
And what we found one of first experiments when looking at these
connections between the nervous system and brain tumors, is that they are
actually synaptic contacts on a portion of these
tumor cells here looked at with electron microscopy.
So we stained tumor cells with a tumor specific marker, which makes them
DAB
positive and showing here in an electron dense fashion.
And when you really look at the ultra structure, you see synaptic vesicles from a
neuron, a synaptic cleft, a synaptic density.
So all hallmarks of bona fide synapses that are
connecting from neurons to these tumor cells.
And we find this both in patient or xenograft models, but also
in material from patients.
So this led us to the model that there are unidirectional
synaptic inputs to tumor cells
that then lead to measurable electrophysiological currents that get
translated into calcium events in these tumor cells that then lead to the
proliferation and invasion of tumor cells.
And these findings were already
translated into a clinical phase
one, two trial, the PERSECH trial, where we'd use perampanel to
disconnect tumors from their neurons using a
non-competitive AMPA receptor antagonist, which we usually use for
therapy-resistant epilepsy. And the primary endpoints in this
trial are basically based on an RNA Seq
connectivity score, as well as AI-based MRI growth dynamics.
I think it's clear that we also need to understand on a really
ultra structural basis
what really happens when we give patients this perampanel.
So I think it's important that we also further develop
bespoke translation readouts for neuronal
connectivity in glioblastoma patients.
And to do so, and to really also trace these neuron to
tumor networks across
the entire brain, which is simply not easily possible
by simply using patch clamp electrophysiology or
ultra structural characterization.
We thought about adapting another technology from
neuroscience, basically rabies-based retrograde tracing for
these brain tumors.
And what happens here is we infect these tumor cells with a
pseudotyped rabies virus that then can jump
monosynaptically to presynaptically connected
neurons. And when doing so, what you can visualize
are the dynamics of how connectivity forms in
these brain tumor cells. And you see basically here in the white color
the tumor cells that are invading and proliferating, and all
these green cells are lighting up in the mer...
Let's basically say within 100 hours, you see how
almost all neurons light up that are getting
connected
with these tumor cells,
showing basically that this is a dynamic phenomenon, that they are transient
synaptic contacts, and that they are widespreadWhen you look
at this from a whole brain perspective and map basically these
tumors to the entire brain and their connected neurons, what you can see is
even when the tumor is here in a very local part of the brain,
you see basically this dense green rim around it.
This is the proximal neuronal connectome.
But you see also all these green signals throughout the entire brain, even on the
contralateral side, which makes it clear that even if the tumor is
local, the brain tumor is brain-wide
simply by proxy, by its connectome of connected
neurons.
When looking at specific circuits again, and here we looked at the
rationale of understanding the basal forebrain connections,
which is amazingly acetylcholine-ergic, and looking at
connected cortical areas, what we could find is
that there are also other neurotransmitters besides glutamate that
seem to play a role for driving glioblastoma invasion and
proliferation. We could see that when you co-culture
cholinergic neurons with tumor cells, again, their invasion
speed increases as well as their proliferation.
And when you look at circuit-specific tumor cells
that are connected with the basal forebrain, you can see that if you knock
down a certain muscarinergic subunit, that overall
tumor development in that particular cortex area
significantly also decreases, which makes it clear that we need to
understand also these cancer in a circuit-specific manner.
So we talked a lot about neuron to tumor synaptic
connections.
What we're beginning to understand over the last 10 years is that there are more
and more also other types of tumor networks, that there are
tumor cells that are connecting other tumor cells via gap junctions
and tunneling nanotubes. But there are also gap junctions between
astrocytes and tumor cells.
Focusing on these other types of networks, we sought to
understand how basically the molecular
heterogeneity of cancer cells as well as their
connectivity is interconnected.
And for this purpose, we again were able to leverage
and separate paradigm from neuroscience using a
functional imaging dye called S111, usually
used in neuroscience to label astroglia.
And we knew beforehand that the portion of tumor cells
take up this dye, indicating astrocytic
and intertumoral connectivity, whereas another
portion of these tumor cells did not take up this dye.
We could leverage neuroscience technologies such as in vivo time-lapse
imaging, looking live at these two tumor cell
subpopulations in the living mouse brain and studying glioma cell
invasion. And on the other hand, we're able to
also leverage single cell RNA sequencing
and beforehand FACS sorting these two populations
and integrating basically the molecular heterogeneity with a
functional outcome.
And when doing so, what we could see
is that these tumor cells that are not connected with other tumor
cells,
those are the ones that are from the molecular phenotype,
neuronal-like NPC and OPC-like related.
Whereas those tumor cells that are connected with each other
and/or astrocytes are much more reflected in the mesenchymal and
AC-like molecular subtypes, which again are in
turn much more resistant towards standard of care therapy.
When looking further into these phenotypes, what we could see is that these
unconnected tumor cells
resemble really immature neurons during neurodevelopment,
featuring their neural mechanisms, and again, also via
transient synapses are able then to invade into the
brain.
When looking at a completely different
tumor entity, looking here basically at supratentorial ependymoma.
This is work we've been doing together with Mariella
Philbin, who has led this work and really led us into this
tumor entity. When doing so, what we could see is that there's
also a lot of morphological
heterogeneity
that again, can be related to the molecular atlas that she
developed, that we can overlay with these different types of morphology, and in the
end, also can see that again, also in
supratentorial ependymoma, a neuronal-like
subpopulation is the one that drives
invasion into the brain. So basically also resembling,
again, the work that we did in glioblastoma and showing again that
is another pediatric tumor entity.
When looking now into the subcellular
mechanisms and really understanding whether these neuronal
mechanisms are also reflected on a
subcellular level,
we were again turning to neuroscience and wanting to understand,
do these neurite-like protrusions in these
tumor cells follow the same
playbook as axonal growth cones during
neuronal migration? And there in these
neuronal growth cones, local translation of
mRNAs is a major deciding factor in
really guiding
neurons to the place where the neurites need to go.
And when we looked in our tumor cells, again, here,
this is the neural soma, and you see basically these long
neurite-like protrusions, which we call tumor microtubules.
What you can see on an ultrastructural basis is that you can
find ribosomes throughout the entire tumor cells with
an enrichment even at the outer tip of these tumor
cells.When you overlay this also again on an RNA
level, you can nicely see that there are also transcripts, again with an
enrichment towards the end, so basically at the growth
cone of these tumor cells.
And lastly, what you can see when you use a puromycin
readout, again indicating actual translation,
you can nicely see that there's also a local translation actually going on
in these neurite-like protrusions.
We can now actually separate also somata
from these neurite-like protrusion using a so-called insert
assay, and basically sequence these two compartments
separately and then understand what actually differs
in these tumor cells as compared to their somata.
And when doing so and using basically the overexpressed
tumor microtubule genes and really try to basically,
only using the differentially expressed genes, try to recluster these genes, what
we can see is that basically those
genes that are upregulated in the tumor microtubule
are the ones that can define cell states much better than
those that are significantly upregulated
within the soma itself as compared to the TM.
Which shows again that this is a very specialized subcompartment that
is able to identify and also characterize
cell states and cell identity. Again, this is also resembling
work that has been shown during neurodevelopment, where the
neurites can have a completely different molecular composition
than the somata and define actually cell states also in neurons.
And when looking at the specific genes that are upregulated
in tumor microtubules, what we could find, again, is a
molecule called GPM6A as compared to other
genes where we knew that they play a role like GAB43,
and that
GPM6A is a driver of tumor microtubule
formation and invasion. You can nicely see this.
This is a long tumor microtubule, and you see basically here in the purple color,
the GPM6A protrusions that really are formed on top of
these tumor microtubules. And when, again, knocking this down,
what you can nicely see is that, again, tumor invasion is
mainly driven by this GPM6A overexpression.
Again, also a molecule very much involved in dendrite
development,
coming from neuronal development again.
With this, I would just want to close and hope I could convince you
that really developing and adapting these types of
neuroscientific methodology across scales is really important to
study cancer neuroscience in model systems, but also in human
tissues. That we really want to
understand these cancer connectomes, so understanding
tumors in their entirety, similar to what neuroscientists are doing with the
brain, slicing it up, looking at their connections.
This is what I believe also that's something that we need to do for
brain cancers. And lastly, the vision that we are pursuing is
that by disconnecting tumors from their
microenvironment, that this is a viable strategy to make these
tumors much more amenable to standard of care therapies.
With this, I want to close and want to summarize that we have shown
neurotumor synaptic networks that drive brain tumor progressions.
There are neural mechanisms on cellular and subcellular levels
that drive both heterogeneity and tumor cell
invasion. That you can actually target these tumor
networks and develop novel therapeutic
strategies. And lastly,
I hope I could convince you that cancer neuroscience is an emerging field that
really allows us novel insights and hopefully also
gives us some guidance for the future.
For this, I want to thank my fantastic team, all of the
collaborators in Germany and across the entire world,
the patients and tumor, and their families who donated tissues, and I want to
thank you for your attention.
Thank you. We have a few minutes for questions.
Is this recording?
I get it. I do not try.
Yeah, that's true.
Yes, maybe now.
Beautiful, fantastic work.
I was wondering if you could comment on the potential immune
contribution to these cancer neuron synapses that you are seeing, the
same way that microglia are pruning these synapses during
development. Do you think they play a role also in this cancer
context? And then as maybe a second angle to that, do you
think we can recapitulate this beautiful biology also with mouse models?
I know we're working here with human PDX all injected into immunocompromised mice.
Do you think we're missing something by using these mice that are
lacking certain immune components?
Yes. Thank you so much for these questions.
So I think this is definitely a novel frontier
also for the field of cancer neuroscience to really understand what
both innate and adaptive immune system is doing.
And again, also, this is a caveat definitely for our work, where we have
mostly focused on patient-derived xenograft models looking
in immunodeficient context. But to answer your question, so
actually, yes, we have
seen definitely the contribution of microglia and actually exactly the
phenotype that you're describing of pruning synapses that play a
major role also for these neuron tumor interactions
in work that we have not publishedYet.
And the other question is, can we recapitulate this in
mouse models? And I was also always quite skeptical about this
until actually last week when I got finally
convinced
by work from Diana Shye's lab looking at IDH
mutant astrocytoma, and basically we can very
nicely see these very beautiful morphologies in their
syngenic mouse model. So I believe that there are good mouse models as well.
So I'm hoping, and I think it's important to actually study also things like the
immune system.
Yeah. Super. Thank you so much.
Hey, Arun.
Hi.
Great work. I was wondering, have you seen microtubules in other
types of glioma, like pediatric IDH mutant, but also other types of brain
tumors, medullo, meningio,
you name it?
Yes. It's a very good question. And I would say,
so basically we have looked at this phenotype in various
pediatric entities, which again, I would say
almost all of the primary brain tumors show this.
In meningioma, we haven't seen them.
In brain metastases, it's almost only in
NSCLC and a very particular brain metastatic
phenotype. So I would say,
it really depends on the tumor entity, but I'm also sure that we'll find, and we
have seen some of this work also in extracranial cancers.
So I believe that
it's really tumor entity dependent.
Right. Thank you.
Hey. Kind of quick question regarding about can create a kind of in vitro model
system to recapture the cancer neuron interactions.
I'm kind of curious, so for us, quite new in the
field, right? So we want to establish a system in the lab.
But if the tumor, for example, the tumor from cortex and the tumor
from brain stem, if we want to use organoid
model to study this, do we need to
use the region-specific kind of organoid model to
create this kind of system? So-
Yeah.
It's a very good question, and so I would like to point here to Michelle
Monje's work, who's trying to exactly dissect these
phenotypes in a very circuit-specific manner-
Mm-hmm
... looking at their various
circuits within the brain. And I think what she's showing very
beautifully is that it's actually exactly what you are saying,
that we really need to look at circuit-specific
tumors and really also their connection because they're hijacking
anatomical connections. And I mean, this is also what we could reflect in our
own model system when looking at cholinergic
input. So yes, I would say the region
does play an important role when treating these tumors.
Thank you.
Last question quickly.
Hi. Thank you so much for the talk. I was just wondering if you could talk a little
bit more about targeting these tumor networks and how
maybe some off-target effects might happen when using perampanel or other agents.
Yes. That's the most important question, right?
So we see also during the clinical trial now that
perampanel is a drug that needs very careful
titration because obviously you suffer from
neuropsychiatric side effects.
So definitely, finding targets
that preserve the central nervous system integrity
while tackling tumor-specific effects, this is
the challenge of the entire field.
So what I think is needed is to use trials like
these as a first starting point to really dive down into the
molecular mechanisms that are specific to tumor cells and then find
treatments that we can use.
All right. Great. Thank you.
So to continue with the theme of tumor networks, perfect segue to the last
question. Our next speaker is Daniel Azarin from ETH Zurich.
Thank you, Mario. Thank you, everyone. Hello.
So today we'll be talking about a screening platform that we developed as part of
my PhD, where we can actually target these tumor-tumor networks.
But before talking about this, I would like to thank the ACR for their support
towards the years. So I was happy to get the Scholarship Training Award back in
Orlando '23, where I was able to...
You can see here with my poster talking about this story, it still was being
cooked. And now three years later, I'm still here showing this to you, so I'm
really happy and thankful to them.
And before we start, so as well, I would like to also thank
my supervisors, former supervisor, Fran Winckler and Sophie Hoya, as well
as Dirk Hofmann, a postdoc at my former lab for the support
to get this publication published.
We published early this year, and we also made it to the cover, so I was really
excited about that. And as Bahram was already
introducing, I was studying tumor microtubule networks.
In this case, I only focused on tumor-tumor networks.
And so what you can see is these tumor microtubules.
What they're going to do, they're going to invade the brain, as you can see here in
this video from Matthias Oswald. And then you can see how we can follow up with
intravital microscopy for up to two months.
And then you can see how as well when we treat the tumors with radiotherapy, so a
standard of care treatment, you can see how, for example, unconnected
cells are going to die down here. But then, connected ones, they're going
to survive and resist. And we also see these
networks in human samples, so we can also distinguish two
niches. So we can see the tumor core, which is actually, as you can see here with
the nest in a staining,
where the majority of the networks are being formed.
And as Bahram was saying before as well, then there is invasion zone, where
actually the cells are going to connect to neurons and also
invade and colonize the brainAnd
these networks are really functional and they are really alive, as you can see here
as well from a video from Mathias Oswald paper in 2015, and then you can see
how all of this calcium communication is happening as
well with intra vital microscopy.
And David Hausmann and the team published a few years ago how within this
network there is specific type of hubs, so they are called
pacemaker-like cells or periodic cells, and those are the
ones that are going to dictate the rhythm of the network.
And actually, once you target those in a specific manner,
the tumors don't grow anymore. But whereas when you do random damage
to the whole network,
still they're going to resist.
And so one can think of these tumor microtubules also expressing
different molecular markers such as, for example, TTYH2, GAB43, which again,
are markers that normally are expressed in the brain in development.
And they also express Connexin43.
It's one of the molecules in charge of this calcium
exchange and firing that I showed you before.
So, of course, eventually all of these things are going to
allow the networks and the tumors to survive.
So the main idea
of this paper and my PhD project, it was actually to design
a disconnecting therapy, something that also I won't explain now.
And so we designed a platform because we thought that that was missing currently in
the literature. So the idea was to really find
drugs that actually disconnect those networks.
And then once they are sensitive and they are really disconnected, then to target
them with the standard of care treatments to be able to
find new cures for these lethal diseases.
And so the first challenge was to actually come up with an in vitro system that
actually recapitulates what we see, what I showed you already in the human case.
So you can see here human glioblastoma samples using Nestin and
then also with our mouse model PDX so we also see these networks.
And so we came up with a system, which we call 2D TM assay, that actually also
shows this nice network. So once we had this on our hands,
I was training the model, an algorithm.
I use Elastic, which is an open source algorithm using the random
forest,
basically algorithm. This machine learning basic feature.
And then I was taking so many images of control, but also with other treatments to
kind of see different phenotypes.
And then once I trained this algorithm and I was happy now with the results, then
we eventually get the probability maps, the segmentation maps, and
therefore at the end, I was able to get objective results on the number
of tumor microtubules, the length, and also other parameters such as
total cells and dead cells.
So after this, we came up with 71 drugs,
divided in 13 classes. And we just have some knowledge
about different papers we published in the past, but also about RNA sequencing
and also some other targets that we thought could be interesting to
try and find new targets to target these networks.
And so the first thing we did, we just seed the cells.
We let them grow for 24 hours in our in vitro system.
And once we see networks, we actually treat them, and then we do live cell
microscopy. And then what you can see here, for example, is some different drugs.
So it's really important to mention that I didn't want to focus on
a target that actually kills the cells, but rather, a drug
that actually disconnect the cells.
So as you can see, for example, compound A17 or DO2, these ones we didn't care
about. We just use as a negative control,
because they are, of course,
disconnecting cells, but they are also killing the cells, as you can see here, with
the Ethidium Homodimer
cellular death marker. So this one we discard it also because most
of them, they were targeting actin filament, so something we cannot really
translate eventually to the clinics or in vivo even.
And so at the end, we came up with a Class C here,
and those are PKC activators, so protein kinase C activators.
We found two hits, PMA and TPBB. And those
actually led to a decrease of the number and parameters of tumor microtubules, but
still, they didn't kill the cells. So those were our two hits.
And then eventually we also move to validate this with three glioblastoma cell
lines, which you can see here on the left side.
This, we were able to prove that there is a morphological disconnection
of these
tumor microtubules that we can quantify now with our morphometry-based pipeline, as
well as a functional
silencing of the calcium activity.
So you can see up the videos how the overall calcium signal is decreased, as
well as here down with the calcium traces, we can see also the
periodic cells that I introduced before, they are also
completely
silenced. So that was really exciting.
And then we collaborated with Sandra Hosic in Mannheim to work on
something more relevant, a 3D system.
And in this case, we came up with this human glioblastoma in brain spheroid model,
which actually is about iPSCs, astrocytes, and neurons, and then we
culture with the glioblastoma cell lines.
And then what you can see here is that we see the morphological features that I
already showed you on human, mouse, and in vitro only, and now we also see them
with this
spheroid model. And also, they are functional.
So it was the best scenario, like the best platform to kind of
continue testing our drugs before we actually move to the in vivo
pipeline. And we did so, and we found the same phenotype.
So actually this TPBB1 was disconnecting the tumor microtubules,
again in
this system. And unfortunately, even though it's not shown here, PMA
didn't disconnect the tumor cells in this case, so therefore, we
just moved on with
TPBB for the next steps. And so here what we designed as well is an in
vivo drug discovery pipeline, where we have these
immunocompromised mice. We do a chronic corneal window, and then we inject the
cells. We let them grow, and then we monitor with intra vital two-photon
microscopy. And once we see a good network, connected cells, we
start to treat them with these disconnecting agents, and we give radiotherapy on
top.And we can do longitudinal studies, again, with two-photon
microscopy. And in this case, I also designed a 3D image
analysis pipeline. And the good thing about this is that we can get our
data of intra-vital microscopy, but we can also get the tissue and
do downstream analysis, as I will explain also in a few slides later.
And so this is the automated 3D in vivo image analysis part.
So here what we do, we follow up always using the vessels, so that we can
find always the same region in the mouse brain.
And then in this case I use IVIA, which is a commercial solution, I think offered
by Leica, but it's the same idea. I just like the platform.
It was really user-friendly, and it was easy to work with these large
3D volumes. And at the end I get the same, so I get pixel probability maps of
the
TMs as well as their cell bodies, and eventually we can get
our quantitative analysis. And so this is how it
looks. This is a volume of a two-photon microscopy of a mouse
41 days after tumor implantation, and then you can see how we can now detect and
identify tumor microtubules when we are scrolling the 3D volume,
as well as we can see in a 3D manner also
the tumor cells.
So that was
why then after this, we moved to actually try this drug in vivo.
And what we saw really fast in combination with radiotherapy, as you can see on the
left side, is two weeks after radiotherapy, we
saw only a few disconnected cells up here.
And then of course when we did analysis postmortem of these mice treated with them,
we saw the tumor area was completely eradicated.
And of course, we were expecting as well a survival benefit that we were able to
see.
And now you might be wondering what it's going on with the--
what it's changing in these kind of treatment or treated cells that
actually allows us to see this drastic phenotype.
So we did RNA bulk sequencing of our three glioblastoma cell lines.
And then we saw that TTYH2, which is one of these
molecular markers of tumor microtubules that I explained before, it was
downregulated. But this is again, just RNA bulk sequencing.
So what we did, we used the Lunafort COMET
system
to have both RNA and protein in the same slide.
I think they
have a booth here in the exhibition hall, so if you want to pass by later to learn
more about this technique. But basically, I designed four RNA scope
probes that they were really interesting for me, and then a bunch
of other antibodies. And so what we can see at the beginning with this, and it
was really powerful, is that we can identify all the
parts that I showed you before. So we can see the tumor core, but then we can, of
course,
try and understand the invasion zone, and then to try and really, a
spatially resolved manner, understand the expression of this TTYH1
molecule within the tumor network, but also in the invasion zone.
And so what we saw
is there is a higher expression of TTYH1 in the invasion
zone compared to the tumor core. And these we were able to see,
again, using RNA scope together with, here in magenta, with the nestin antibody.
And we can also
quantify these dots and have the
numbers as well about this.
So then how does it look when we treat the mice
with this TPPB PKC activator, and then we perform this
multi-omic assay? So it looks like this.
We have also a decrease
in the tumor core, but we also have a decrease in the invasion zone, which is more
dramatic.
But overall, what we saw is
TPPB treatments or PKC activators is actually decreasing the
expression of TTYH1, which is really visual in the invasion zone because it's
where this TTYH1, it's expressed there and it's
in the invading part of the brain.
And also what we did, again, with
this COMET technology, is to, again, quantify the nestin
signal here and quantify that there are actually less
TMs per cell as well as the length. And we also were able to show
using RNA scope how MKI67 dots, so
proliferating cells decrease with the treatment as well as caspase
3, so
cells dying increase
with this treatment as well.
And finally, in collaboration with Miriam Radcliff, I was able to also
test these drugs in a more translational human relevant
context. So she's working with these tumoroids, patient-derived organoids,
and here I also tested this drug with radiotherapy, and we saw that there was
a decrease of number of TMs that we can see here with the nestin stain, and here
the cells appear more roundish. But most importantly, the expression of
TTYH1 also was compromised.
So with this, I hope I was able to convince you about this disconnecting drug and
all the different effects that it's going to cause in
glioblastoma disease. So we have to identify through this platform and
screen TPPB, which is actually a PKC activator, that it's going
to phosphorylate PKC while decreasing the expression of TTYH1,
and this is going to have different consequences.
So in the invasion zone, because this was TTYH1 is highly expressed,
it's going to
truncate the invasion driven by TMs, as well as the
network anatomy is going to be disrupted as well.
And most importantly, the functional connectivity, as we discussed before also
with the pacemakers, is going to be silenced, which will result in
a boost radiotherapy
and animal survival, as well as a decrease in the tumor growth.
And now what it's going next, I'm following up on what I like
to call functional omics. So in this case, also in collaboration with colleagues
from the ETH as well as with Miriam Radcliff, we're trying to get these
biopsies from a patient in a tumor and tumoroids, and then we
seed them in a mono layer. And then the idea is to take different
videos at different time points, different network densities, and then
to really correlate these frequencies and these calcium
data with different expression patterns, again, using COMET platform
and, of course, using RNA probes and proteins.As well.
And so you can also find this review or opinion article that I was
also happy to be part of, where I speak about these
functional omics. And also, and this to conclude, where I talk about the
future, what I think is the future of cancer research for the next years, which I
think it's cancer neuroscience, as Bahram was also introducing today.
In my case, I focus only on cancer intrinsic neural futures,
but also yesterday there was a session about cancer neuroscience, and so I think
there is going to be a lot of new things going on in this emerging field.
So with this, I would like to thank my lab in the ETH, Andrea Smorelab, as well as
the Innosuisse, which is a funding agency that actually allowed me to also be in
Luna Forum site to learn this multi-omics workflow and to understand
for that in collaboration with the academy and industry.
And lastly, of course, my former lab, Professor Binkley Lab,
and all the colleagues for the support through the years.
Thank you so much, and I'm happy to take questions.
We have time for a few questions.
Hi, thank you. Very exciting talk.
Lisa from Cosine Therapeutics. So, can you help me relieve
my curiosity how these intracellular tumor
microtubules are radio protective?
So what's mechanistically? And is it only radiation specific,
this sort of effect, or does it extend to alkylating
agents or any other treatments?
That's right. So the tumor microtubules, also TMs, so basically one of the
things they can do, they can buffer calcium levels in a way so they can
somehow avoid and escape cellular death.
So that's one of their kind of features.
But yeah, there is another paper published where we basically
saw the same with temozolomide.
Mm-hmm.
So basically also with chemotherapy, and that's
how they can... Yeah, being connected, it protects them against
this standard of care treatment. Yeah.
Thank you.
No worries.
Mark.
Yep. Very nice work.
Quick question. On your in vivo study or survival,
you did see a prolongation of survival, but all of the animals
succumbed to the disease. What was the mechanism of resistance
despite disruption of the microtubules?
Can you repeat that again? Because I-
Sure. So you showed us in the in vivo
studies-
Mm-hmm
... the preclinical in vivo study, a prolongation of survival.
Right.
But the animals did all subsequently
die from tumor.
What was the mechanism? Did they find a workaround to the disruption
of the microtubules? How did they
regrow?
Yeah, that's a good question. I think also we found some toxicity due
to the radiotherapy that we give them.
So we find also the brain at some point with some edema, which
also can lead to death. But yeah,
I don't know the answer, sorry for that.
So-
But I guess, yeah.
So I guess I'm asking the question from the perspective of translation of
this-
Yeah
... into the clinic. If we can anticipate what the mechanism of
resistance might be, we could then
include that therapy to now
target the resistance mechanism and
further enhance the effectiveness.
Yeah. This is a good point. TBV translation, it's being used in Alzheimer's
disease, but I guess it's not that attractive to the kind of
translational field. We just saw here like a platform to screen for that.
But I guess, yeah, one would have to do more studies to understand your questions.
But I guess, yeah, it's a really good point, but,
yeah, I don't know the answer unfortunately.
But-
Thank you
... thank you.
Hi. Thanks for the fantastic talk. I have a few questions.
The first one is, why did you use nude mice and not
immunocompetent?
So, basically we have these human glioblastoma cell lines, so
because they come from a human background-
Yeah
... we cannot inject it in a mouse with an immune system because otherwise, the
tumors-
But-
... wouldn't grow.
Yes, but maybe could you use a murine GBM cell lines to also
dissect the immune component?
I guess you could, and I think there are studies showing TMs in these murine cell
lines, but I just focus on-
Okay
... human samples because it's the background of my former lab, so we just focus on
that.
Yes.
Yeah.
Thanks. And the other question is that how long the disconnection
lasts, and how does that inform dosing?
Do you mean in vitro or?
No, in the in vivo one.
In vivo model. Yeah, so, actually this is more questions to answer.
We have to do better studies to understand the time it takes to-
Okay
... disconnect them. And so,
yeah, I don't have... We just took several... Yeah, I think I have an extra slide.
So I showed you before the invasion zone, but then here, of course,
is the tumor core, and here, it takes longer-
Okay
... for the treatment to have an effect.
So you can see here, for example,
it's taken something like more than a month to see this effect, whereas in the
invasion zone, it took two weeks. So that's something we also to understand and
to follow up on this, like the timing and also concentrations and so on.
Okay. Final question. Are you considering to try other therapeutic
strategies besides radiotherapy?
I guess one can think about also combination with the Temozolomide, yeah.
But, I didn't do that for this study.
Okay. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Last question.
Yeah. So,
sorry. So the PKC activator could affect a lot of
pathways, right? Kind of phosphorylation status.
I'm kind of curious how you kind of narrow down which kind of the
downstream and target, or just like a certain phosphorylation as
critical for this microtubule formation.
Another follow-up question is about, so whether this activator
only disrupt the
tumor microtubule formation but not the
connection of the neuron and the tumor cells?
That's a good question. Yeah, and there is a lot of literature on PKC activators
and how at some point when you activate them too much, there is a loop that
actually ends up in inhibition, right?
So I guess it's really complex, this family of drugs, and in my case, of course, we
found this hit.But I didn't focus that much on the translational
part of it. I focused on providing a platform to kind of screen for all the drugs.
And of course, yeah, these interactions with
Niro, I think it's also something that needs to be studied, right?
When do you want to suggest a future clinical trial?
But in my case, I don't see this drug as a really translational drug for now, but
I wanted to really focus on the methods and designing a platform.
So yeah, there is a lot of controversy about PKC activators, and I think a lot of
studies need to be done to answer these specific questions. Yeah.
Thank you.
All right. We're going to switch gear now to also focus on other compartments of
the tumors, and we're going to discuss the tumor microenvironment, and we have
Dolores Hambardzumyan from
UPenn.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much for organizers.
Thank you very much, Mario, for putting this beautiful symposium together, and
thank you everyone that during this busy day and a lot of choices, you are here
today in this room to hear about progress that we have and the science
that is ongoing in glioblastoma. I'm going to talk about myeloid subset
today, so I'm going to start with just saying I have no
disclosure, financial disclosure to report, but I have a lot of
acknowledgments to start with, and I want to thank my lab members here,
my current lab members. I want to thank my former lab members, core
facilities, my collaborators, especially Javier Cordero, he's in
this room, sitting in the front row, and other collaborators, of course,
funding agencies. And in blue, I highlighted people whose work
directly I'm going to talk. The microenvironment is extremely complex in a
very complex disease, so I'm going to try to nail down in a very
cell-specific
information or project that I'm going to give you today on published data.
So just from the big 10,000 view, if you look at the lymphoid and
myeloid compartment of glioblastoma in human here, you can see there is almost
virtually less than 5% T cell infiltration when you have massive
myeloid infiltration in this tumor.
So those are basically T cell depleted and myeloid enriched tumors.
And if you use genetically engineered mouse models of de novo GBM, and here is the
father sitting here at the frontline of generating these models that
closely, they are driven by human GBM-specific driver mutations.
You get tumors that very closely, number-wise, recapitulate
myeloid and lymphoid compartment of human glioblastomas.
But myeloid compartment is very complex.
It's the cells of your innate immune system, and you have multiple subsets of
them. So today, I'm going to specifically focus on two myeloid
subsets, monocytes and neutrophils, that enter GBM from your blood
circulation. So let me just give you a very quick and brief
background about this cell. So they are forming
from hematopoietic stem cells in a bone marrow. They have a common progeny.
It's a granulocytic, monocytic progenitors, and then they diverge into
more lineage-committed cells that give rise to monocytes and
neutrophils in the bone marrow. Then the monocytes and neutrophils that form in
the bone marrow, they exit bone marrow in response to chemokine gradient in
blood circulation, and then you have, like you can see from this
cartoon illustration, you can see more abundant neutrophil presence.
It's approximately a ratio of neutrophil and monocytes, five to one.
So if I can bring you examples of multiple extracranial tumors
where infiltration patterns exactly mimic what you see in the blood,
more neutrophil and less monocytes.
Now, if there is no inflammation,
these monocytes and neutrophils, they have short-lived, neutrophils less than a
day, and monocytes about a day or two, depending which subtype of monocytes we
talk. They disappear, and then you have constantly bone marrow hematopoietic
stem cells generating and pumping them in circulation, keeping everything
constant. But things change when you have
a tumor, and this is a very busy cartoon, but I'll just want to pay
attention. What you see in the blood, abundant neutrophil and
very low monocyte number. The infiltration pattern
actually is reversed in GBM. So you have more monocytes infiltrating
GBM, and the subset of monocytes are CCR2-high.
They gain the name either classic or inflammatory because they are your first line
of defense going into inflammatory site.
And then you have less neutrophils here infiltrating.
And then in the periphery of the tumor, you have beautiful cells line up forming
this rim of the cells, and that's your brain-resident microglia
cells that I will not talk today about.
So my lab for basically 10 years was focused on inflammatory
monocytes, so does many labs, because these cells get from blood
circulation to the brain. They quickly differentiate into tissue
macrophages, and they support tumor growth.
So a lot of effort been focused on targeting these cells, yet
unsuccessfully. It took us 10 years to do that genetically, not
pharmacologically, generate mice that we could trap them in bone
marrow, so they couldn't come to the tumor and promote tumor growth and see what
biological effect we would see on tumor progression.
And to only learn that instead, we got a cellular resistant mechanism
to ablating monocytes infiltration in the form of
accelerated neutrophil infiltration.
So neutrophils became interesting for us.
My lab wasn't neutrophil lab, it's a monocytes and myeloid lab, more
microglia. At that time, so we got interested to understand
neutrophil biology in GBM. Basic question.
And at that time, a talented fellow joined my lab, and she wanted to work on
neutrophils, so I'm like, "Great, we'll learn from you neutrophils, and we'll help
you with mouse models." And she's also ABTA fellow, so her
research is actually funded by ABTA, so we are very grateful for
that.So to do that experiment, first thing was we need to
see face-to-face to meet neutrophils live, how they traffic, how they
migrate. To do that, you took advantage of the mouse that was made by
Matthias Kunze in Germany, who shared kindly with us.
It's called Catch Up Mouse. The name comes from the fact that neutrophils
catch the pathogens. So it's a catch-up mouse.
In fact, it's an LY6G neutrophil-specific RFP
reporter mouse. And she crossed this mouse, this is two, three years of
work to amplify RFP signal to be able to image them by
two-photon imaging. She crossed this mouse into
CX3CR1 GFB mice, and CX3CR1 is expressed in
monocytes, monocyte-derived macrophages, and resident brain
microglia. It's never expressed in neutrophils.
So outcome was generating this, what we call red and green mice.
So this color shouldn't overlap because LY6G is never expressed in
macrophages, and CX3CR1 is never expressed in
neutrophils. Then she recruited a talented fellow in
Javier Cordero's lab, sitting right there taking picture, to do the
imaging together to generate tumors and then live look at
neutrophil trafficking. So this is the multiphoton imaging, so
I won't probably... Let me see. I have time.
You can see how they fly in circulation, but in a naive brain, you don't have
neutrophils. In early-stage tumors, you still don't have neutrophils.
But they noticed that neutrophils start coming when tumor starts
progressing. And the most impressive was looking at end stages when you have
massive necrotic areas and highly hypoxic areas.
You start seeing the third color emerging from red and green.
You start seeing yellow, so mouse transforms from red and green into
traffic light. So the question became: Who are these yellow
cells in a tumor context in a necrotic core?
So this is just a quantification of two-photon images.
So then they did a bit more high-resolution imaging, and here you can see
green macrophages are basically engulfing red color neutrophils.
So they showed, and I'm going to, for sake of time, not go into details, that
neutrophils that infiltrate in necrotic core, they quickly undergo
netosis and release their contacts.
What happens when macrophages see that neutrophils netose and
release their contacts, they come, and they engulf, and this is the
phagosomes, and you can see red neutrophil LY6G protein picked
up by macrophages.
So there comes a question: What does it mean biologically?
What happens to macrophage that engulfs this neutrophil in a
hypoxic and necrotic areas of glioblastoma, which are the
detrimental areas of the tumor? To do that, we first wanted to
understand the human relevance, and she went on and stained this cavita
with IBA-1, which is a macrophage lineage marker, with
MPO, which is matrix metalloprotease in neutrophils, to see if we can
see macrophages in a five-micron sections on human GBM
engulfing this neutrophil content.
And she used classical, proneural, and mesenchymal human GBM
subset, Verhaak, I just so asked a question.
We call them Verhaak subsets in GBM.
And you can see, you see massive engulfment of MPO by macrophages in
human, and it's more pronounced in mesenchymal human GBM that are
known to have higher hypoxia levels, more necrotic areas.
And then she looked exactly the same thing in a murine GBM models that will
basically recreate human avatars by using the same
genetic alteration that are known in human GBM.
That includes EGFR V3-driven tumors, PDGF-driven tumors,
and NF1. I'm looking at the watch.
To understand the biological consequence, what happens when neutrophil netosis and
why do we see neutrophil netosis in hypoxic and necrotic core but not in
other areas, for example, in a perivascular area?
She set up a basic experiment of driving primary neutrophils,
exposing these neutrophils into tumor supernatants, and then
putting these neutrophils in hypoxia and normoxia condition and looking at
netosis. And as you can see here, neutrophil netose and PMA is the
classic netosis marker. And neutrophil netose, those are
NF1-deleted or PDGF overexpressing tumors to make sure this is not a
genotype-specific effect that we observe.
And you can see the effect is more pronounced when you put neutrophils in
hypoxia condition, and netosis, you can see by blue DNA dye
there.
And she did exact the same experiment to figure out human relevance
of this, co-culturing primary neutrophils with the primary human GSC
cultures, both with mesenchymal and classic proneural signature.
And you can see that neutrophils in human, if anything, netose much higher
degree. It's twice higher netosis levels, and they are more sensitive.
They netose even in normoxia conditions when you expose them to
tumor supernatants.
Then to understand the question of yellow that appeared in a red and green mice in
a necrotic core, what happens to macrophages when they pick up
neutrophil content? She set up three co-culture experiments.
The neutrophils that were exposed to human cell supernatants and
then into normoxia and hypoxia. Then she used that supernatants to
expose macrophages primary and see what happens to macrophages.
And she used the MPOs. You can see here the
green one, CM FDA, is the macrophage dye, so it labels all
macrophages. And when you add neutrophils here, you can see that they pick
up MPO that is released from neutrophil supernatants.
But to understand biological consequence, okay, they picked up MPO and a
lot of other things that were in the supernatants of netotic neutrophils.
What happens to macrophage after that?
As you can see, she looked at the various markers of immunosuppression, arginase
1 being one, and you can see that it's upregulated when macrophages are
exposed to neutrophil supernatants, and the effect is more enhanced when
it's in a hypoxic condition. And then she generated MPO
knockout neutrophil co-culture and subjected them in hypoxia and
normoxia, and this effect was downregulated when MPO was not
there.Then she looked at a bunch of other immunosuppressive molecules
like CD204, 206, PD-L1. And now you're all wondering,
okay, immunosuppressive molecules are expressed, so what's the functional
consequences of those? Do they change?
To do the functional consequences, she set up now four culture experiments.
Those are very tedious, difficult primary experiments, and looked, took
the supernatants from neutrophils that were exposed to tumor cells,
and damped that supernatants on T cell cultures. They suppressed T cells.
So neutrophil content can suppress T cell culture.
And then she exposed macrophages into the supernatants.
And then neutrophil-trained macrophages she used in T cell co-culture
experiments, and that's what you see happens when macrophages are
exposed and picked up MPO from the neutric neutrophil, they
suppress T cell function. And then she also looked at the inhibitory
checkpoint molecules. They are all upregulated.
Now I still have three minutes. Now, this was all in vitro, and you're all
wondering, this is in vitro, did you go and do mouse experiment?
That was just the first thing Kavita did.
She did generate tumors in MPO proficient and deficient mice, and
subjected them to single-cell RNA sequencing to narrow down
where we go next. And this is the myeloid cell
subset present, and I just want you to focus now on the neutrophils.
And when she look at the cell density plots from MPO proficient and deficient
tumor, as you can appreciate, the biggest difference she noticed was increased
number of neutrophils. So MPO deficient tumors have
higher neutrophil content.
Then she needed to validate single-cell sequencing result by
multiplex fax flow cytometry,
and this is the TSNE plots of myeloid cells from facts.
And you can see, just like in single cells, she validated actual
neutrophil numbers is increased. And this is the quantification.
Then of course comes number of cell is increased.
What happens to phenotype? We show that phenotypically, when you manipulate
MPO in culture experiments, you actually block netosis formation.
So she looked at the phenotype and oxidative burst, ROS production, and
netosis module scores were reduced in MPO-deficient
neutrophils. And then antigen presentation score was increased.
So these neutrophils lost their identity. They don't netose.
Their number gets higher because they don't die, so we can preserve, and their
number increases, and they gain APC-like presenting, become
like APC-like cells in the tumors.
And then she validated some of those markers using flow cytometry.
You can see class two expression is upregulated in MPO knockout mice.
PD-L1 level, so many other immunosuppressive molecules were
also downregulated. And of course, the question comes.
Cell lost the identity because we took out the major
matrix metalloprotease that has a tremendous function in the cell.
What happens to the cell? And we increase their accumulation.
So to understand what's the biological consequences of all the changes we
observed, she did the survival experiments with the most aggressive GBM
model we have, which is the NF1 silenced model, and more neutrophil-dependent
model. As you can see, there's a significant shift in survival for
MPO knockout mice compared to MPO proficient tumor.
And she split them by sex because there are reports showing sex-dependent
differences in myeloid-affected tumors. There's no difference there.
So if I can summarize, and I have 45 seconds to do.
In a very simple way to put, so we have in a normal
circumstances, in a MPO proficient tumor, so we have
neutrophils that come and netose, and note that human neutrophils
netose much faster. So in any effect we see in the mouse models, probably it's
going to be stronger in human case.
And then macrophages come and phagocytose these neutrophils, and
they turn more immunosuppressive in a hypoxic and necrotic core of the tumor.
And we know that's true in human macrophages in GBM as well, when they are in
hypoxic core from Henry Qialin's work.
And then today, I didn't talk about the time, but there is also
reduction of T cells in this context and poor survival.
You remove an MPO, you increase more immunostimulatory, both
neutrophil and macrophage number, you increase T cell infiltration, and I didn't
show today for the time it's CD8-driven effect, and then you improve
the survival of the mice. And just exactly at nine second, I
hope I didn't speed. I have a tendency, but I'm happy to take the questions.
Questions for Dolores. Royal.
Yeah. Really nice talk. I wondered if you looked at brain mets, where
the tumor microenvironment is a little different, and if you see the same
phenomenons there?
Yeah, it's a great question. It's the next.
That's what Javier's lab is going to do with the mice with them at Mount Sinai.
We're going to look at the brain tumor metastasis microenvironment too, and you're
absolutely correct, because myeloid and T cell infiltration
patterns are reversed. The primary brain tumors have higher
myeloid, lower lymphoid, and mets have opposite.
Will be great to see in Javier's breast cancer metastasis
models how these cells behave. Thank you.
Thanks for a fantastic talk. I have another curiosity.
So
we saw this image of the brain, how the
cells are spread around the brain from Vern's
talk earlier. So how early do these
microenvironments form? Because we're looking at here at sort of a
necrotic core context or even sort of a big tumor bulk
context. But when the tumor cells migrate
around the brain,
at what point do we expect to start seeing some macrophages?
Yeah.
You know, the time was 15 minutesI could have shown you pictures.
It's a very good question. Neutrophils come very
late with disease progression. So today I showed the multiphoton
imaging data there. What I didn't show about the data on monocytes
infiltrations. And we've done the same experiments with multiphoton
imaging and tracing the cells of tumor nodule.
Even if you have a smallest nodule of the tumor, even if you
have a few cells, you will see them surrounded by CCR2 positive
inflammatory monocytes, and you have beautiful rim-forming
microglia around them. So monocytes, to answer your question, come very
early. Even if you have a bigger tumor, and tumor is in one side, in
a contralateral side, you have through white matter tracking a mouse,
tumor cells migrating, you will see one tumor cell surrounded four,
five monocytes there. Yes, pretty early.
Mark.
Dolores, great talk.
Thank you.
So in trying to extrapolate this to
patient situation,
what would you anticipate corticosteroids would do to the
dynamics of these cellular fluxes?
Because all of our patients get steroids.
This is a great question. So
my lab actually studies the brain tumor edema also.
I realize I never talk about it.
And we looked at what dexamethasone does when we treat mice, and
dexamethasone inhibits IL-1, which is a major pro-inflammatory
cytokine, and changes completely myeloid and lymphoid
profile in this tumor. So that's why I think for this particular case,
we haven't looked really what happens to neutrophil when you treat them with
dexamethasone. That's a very great question to do, but we looked at the monocytes
number was very much decreased. This is, I think, one of the good
cases when we have a dex naive in a mouse models that are very
closely resembling their human counterparts to look at this effect.
Thank you.
Great talk.
Two questions again on the translational aspects of it.
You can take out the core of the tumor in many different ways.
So the necrotic hypoxic center in some ways can be
addressed clinically in at least a subset of patients.
So I just wondered your thoughts on what that might imply,
in terms of the mechanism that you like the periphery of the tumor and how that
might influence that. Second question is hypoxia seems to
be important. So you've done hypoxia reversal sort of
approaches?
Yeah, so-
Would that be relevant in this case in a different way?
Very nice. So let me just so I don't forget first question.
So it's true, we debulk the tumor. It's a very fair point, right?
We debulk the tumor and the core is gone.
So that's monocytes and neutrophils that are mainly populating the
parenchyma of the tumor, and you have few tumor cells probably escaped,
surrounded by microglial cells. You know microglia secretes the
highest level of monocytes recruitment chemokine, CCLs, and microglia
also recruits neutrophils. So when tumors recur in a recurrent,
you see even more monocytes than neutrophils. So this becomes a pattern.
It's not that recurrence is going to be different.
If anything, the myeloid number is higher in a recurrent tumors.
So that's still a challenge for us to target them.
And second question was about-
The hypoxia and the-
Hypoxia. Yeah,
so this is
super interesting. So we're now, Kavita is analyzing,
necrotic regions and hypoxic with GLAT1 hypoxic areas in
embryo knockout tumors to see whether neutrophils
are consequence of the necrosis and hypoxia.
They die in that conditions faster, or they are actually contributing
drivers of formation of the structures.
I think, right now I don't have the data, but it's great and she's looking
into it. We'll know. Thank you. It was a great question.
Thank you, Dolores.
Thank you.
All right. Thanks to all of you for sticking to the end of the session.
So my name is Marios Suva. I'm an investigator at Mass General Hospital, and
I'm going to conclude this session by discussing our effort into
mapping gliomas with the various single-cell and spatial genomics
technologies. This is my disclosure.
And I always like to start with acknowledging the many collaborators the lab has
because it takes a village to do what we do.
So these are a list of some of the people we work with.
And actually, I've probably forgotten some.
I just saw Roel Verhaak before, and he's not on the slide.
So anyhow, a subset of those with whom we work.
Always shout out to Itay Tirosh, who has been my partner in crime for
over a decade, on these studies, and also a lot of work these
days with Dan Landau.
So my lab, since its inception, has really been
focusing aggressively on characterizing human specimen with
various genomics technologies. And we're still trying to basically
answer the same questions that we started with, except over time,
technologies have provided better answer and more powered ones.
But the questions still relate to what is the makeup of these very
complex brain tumors? So what types of lineages those cancer cells are
ascribed with? What type of stem cell programs do they recapitulate?
What types of lineage of differentiation do they recapitulate?
Which subset of cells is actively growing these tumors?
How do these basic phenotypes related to proliferation or developmental cell
states relate to the underlying genetics?
What is the impact of copy number aberration to these phenotypes?
What is the impact of genetic rearrangement on point mutations?
And the idea is really to try to build very high-resolution phylogenetic trees,
dissecting how these tumors evolve, not only from a genetic standpoint, but also
how that impacts the phenotype that is ultimately what is responsible for the
behavior.
And we do that mostly de novo from single-cell data, but we also use the
single-cell data to reinterrogate bulk cohort and try to better
understand disease classification, and other aspects of the
disease.
Traditionally, we're a cancer cell focused lab, but it's impossible to ignore the
microenvironment, so we've also done quite a bit of studies dissecting
myeloid cell components and T-cell elements.So this is the
model that many of you are familiar with because I've presented this too often.
But we think that glioblastoma heterogeneity can be broken down into
four dominant compartments that are a distorted version of neural development.
These terms OPC-like, NPC-like, astrocytic-like, and then a
compartment that's more inflamed and named
mesenchymal-like. And I think the sweet spot of the model is the idea that
depending on the microenvironment feature in which these tumor cells reside or
depending on the underlying genotype and specific genetic alteration, the
equilibrium of the relative proportion of these states can change in any given
sample. We think the basic elements are always the same, but their relative
abundance varies both because of regionality and because of
genetics. And this is the thing that we're trying to better understand.
On the right is a study we had also with Itai a couple of years ago, where we're
trying to spatially map the heterogeneity and place those
elements in the context of the tissue.
And I'm going to briefly discuss that, but I'm going to discuss more unpublished
studies.
This is some of the work we've done in immune space.
Really a lot of work with Kai Wucherpfennig and also David Riordan, who's here, and
Nino Chiocca.
And we've used this technology to really interrogate the programs of T cells in
gliomas. And a few years ago, we highlighted what we think is a novel
pathway by which T cells get inhibited in these tumors.
And more recently, we've been doing a spatial analysis on oncolytic
virus trials of glioblastoma and really showing that
these oncolytic viruses alter the immune microenvironment.
We see massive infiltration of T cells post a single
injection of virus, and we also see that there is quite
substantial cancer cell killing by T cells with direct
evidence of interaction and killing in situ.
So we think at least from a spatial standpoint, a lot
is happening. And I really think for the lab, it's a general philosophy.
We're trying to not only apply and develop these technologies, but
also really deploy them as much as possible in clinical context
because we need to learn more about what happens not only at baseline, but also
how a lot of the clinical trials that ultimately don't necessarily have a
major impact on outcome, but at least we're trying to understand how that alters
the cancer cell's state, the microenvironment, so that we can better understand how
to combine therapies.
This is a revised version of the four-cell states model that we proposed.
There's two manuscripts that we published last year.
The first author of these papers is sitting here, Masashi Nomura.
I really like to highlight his work.
This is a very large cohort that was done in collaboration with many other
centers. We also have Fulvio D'Angelo from the Yavaroni lab here.
And Roel Verhaak was also involved.
And we've really taken 100 samples, done a lot of
single-nucleus analysis, more than half a million single nuclei.
And the idea was try to see if with more power, we would come up with the same
conclusion or different ones. And the very long story very short is that
the structure that we highlighted is not fundamentally different from the four
states model. We can just break them
down in a little bit more granular fashion.
For example, the mesenchymal-like state is now presented in hypoxia,
mesenchymal-like, and stress. These are sub flavors of similar programs, but
it really gives us a little bit more granularity.
I don't think the architecture is fundamentally different.
And if I had more than 15 minutes, I would tell you how we've analyzed how these
programs evolve after therapy. But unfortunately, you'll have to read the
papers if you want to have those answers or discuss directly with Masashi.
So I want to discuss a little bit more of the spatial efforts we're currently doing
in the lab. So as I was mentioning in the short intro, we've done a
first pass at spatial analysis of glioblastoma a couple of years ago with Itai.
And for that, we used a regular Visium platform, so
55 micron capture spot of transcripts.
And we've coupled that with spatial proteomics, highly multiplexed Codex.
And the idea was trying to resolve the spatial organization of these cell states.
And again, just to give you the quick take-home message,
we found that in areas of the tumors where there is necrosis,
these tumors tend to be organized by layers.
And adjacent to this hypoxic necrotic core, you would
have a lot of mesenchymal-like malignant cells and inflammatory
myeloid cells that reside there. This would be adjacently
followed by a kind of angiogenesis hub with vasculature
and more T and B cells infiltration.
And then as you get away from that and you get closer to the
brain parenchyma, you would then have this neurodevelopmental cell state, OPC,
NPC-like, that then interacts with the brain parenchyma.
I think the utility of the model is twofold.
First of all, it's not too surprising that it's organized around necrosis.
We've known that for many years from pathology, but we now have a better molecular
understanding of what the organization looks like.
And also, I'd like to think that we need to think therapeutically of these
different areas as different neighborhoods that require different strategies.
I'm pretty convinced that you've heard beautiful work for cancer neuroscience.
This will be very relevant for this portion of the tumor where there is deep
interaction with the brain parenchyma.
But if we want to target other areas, especially the hypoxic areas, that's
probably unlikely to be the key, and we might need to better
understand how immunosuppression occurs in those areas for those strategies.
So you either look at glioblastoma as four different elements by single-cell states
or different neighborhoods by spatial, but at the end of the day, I think it helps
frame the
idea of how we need to tackle this. I want to spend a little bit of time on some of
our latest effort in more high-resolution spatial analysis.
These are more vignettes. There's no stories because we're writing the paper, so I
don't have solid conclusions, but I just want to highlight what we're currently
doing in the lab just also as a... this idea.
So this is the new Visium HD platform that I'm sure many of you are familiar with.
Two-micron capture RNA instead of 55, so much more resolved.
FFP compatible, so you can really get exquisite morphology from this type of
analysis because you don't rely on frozen samples anymore, and this is work in the
lab led by Chris Mount and his team.
So this is an example. On the left, you have the H&E of a glioblastoma.
We've color-coded here the pia, so the innermost surface of the meninges.
You can see how, in this case, you can follow the pia for a certain point, and
then it's broken at the bottom of the slide.
And this glioblastoma has actually broken into the subarachnoid space and is
now growing in that compartment. On the right is the same analysis
by Visium HD. We've color-coded the level of malignancy present, so anything that's
red is highly malignant. So these are all the malignant cells, and you can also see
some malignant cells in the brain parenchyma that otherwise is mostly containing
normal cells. And so once we have that, we can begin to
assign a certain genetic structure because these assays cover the whole
transcriptome, and so we can use the information to reconstruct the copy
number of the genome. And you can see here that the spots all
have expected gain of chromosome 7 in red.
This is a signature genetic event for primary glioblastoma.
They have a loss of chromosome 10, another signature event, so we know we're
capturing correctly malignant cells.
And then we also have subclonal events that occur in this sample.
And then we can, on the right, spatially map these subclones.
And so you can see how in the brain parenchyma, all these subclones are mixed.
And then in the subarachnoid space, we find they're more regionally
confined, and we see clones
here, for example, in this area, and then in this area, we have the other clones,
some of which are a little bit more intermixed.
But you can see how they're actually quite geographically separated.
So this is the first type of analysis you can do with this assay.
The second type of analysis, you can look at expression.
So in this case, same sample. We now color-coded the expression
states of malignant cells based on the spatial transcriptomics.
You can see here the pia. You can see where it's destroyed.
You can actually now begin to molecularly dissect this area of
infiltration through the pia, how these cells actually break and infiltrate the
leptomeningeal space. You can see how the colors, this is all a simplified
color schematic, but you can see the color of the cells
changes, and you can see that sometimes it's really a function of the
distance from a blood vessel. This is a blood vessel.
Around it, you have specific malignant cell states.
Further away from it, it's a different one.
And so sometimes these states are purely a reflection of where they sit in the
microenvironment. And you can see that in some other instances, actually, this
doesn't seem to be the case. This is another state, and it's not really dependent
on the distance from the blood vessel.
And so it goes back to these questions, how much is genetically dictated?
How much is microenvironmentally dictated in these type of expression programs that
we capture? And so here is an example where we see
both things occurring. So as I've highlighted, the microenvironment
dictates those cell states. But in this area, you can see it's a specific genetic
clone. And so this expression state is mostly related to a genetic clone.
So a lot to disentangle. I'm not claiming we have all the answers, but this is the
type of effort that we're trying to do now at scale to understand how
glioblastoma infiltrates in the leptomeningeal space.
We're doing similar analysis, again, with the same questions, trying to understand
the relationship between genetics and expression with the group of Dan Landau,
where we're doing now single-cell multi-omics,
combining single-cell whole-genome sequencing with single-cell RNA
sequencing, and we do that in a spatially resolved manner in the tissue.
We use slide tags, so we
place spatial tags in the tissue. We recover nuclei that are
spatially positioned, and then we single-cell whole genomes those nuclei and
do RNA sequencing from the same cells.
And the idea is to try to build, again, phylogenetic trees of the evolution of
these tumors and understand the relationship with the microenvironmental features.
So this is a
tree that has been entirely reconstructed based on SNV, so it is purely
based on point mutation. And you can see that we're doing a
pretty decent job at building a tree.
And we know that we're doing a decent job because then we've mapped the copy number
aberration that were not used to build the tree, and you can see how the clades of
copy number actually correspond, they cluster together, and so
the tree makes sense. So we're now doing a lot of work around this.
You might have heard Dan Landau giving the plenary and analyzing all the
ecDNA elements that we find in these
samples. What I would like to highlight in one minute is the idea that
sometimes, and we are trying to understand how
generalizable this is, we see that we
can build those phylogenetic trees,
and then we can ask of the cell states that I've described,
how are they distributed once we build those trees?
And this really gives us direct insight into human samples about
plasticity versus heritability of cell states and maybe the importance of
certain cell states in driving the genetic evolution of these tumors.
You can see here is the most advanced clone in this sample.
This is the most genetically evolved.
And you can see at the bottom color-coded the cell states of glioblastoma, and you
can see how most of the cells that are these genetically advanced are
in this OPC/NPC-like state. So it doesn't seem to be a random distribution of
states. So it's quite possible that at least in some samples, specific state
kind of preferentially evolved the genetics of this tumor.
And again, we're now going to do this at scale to use the information to
really assess heritability and plasticity.
This goes back to what Varun highlighted as well and the beautiful
work he's done and so Frank Winkler, where these cells, these OPC-like
cells, might be preferentially responsible for invasion.
And you can see here in another study we recently published
where this is a xenograft of these tumors in the mouse brain.
And we're actually asking what programs allow these cells to cross
the midline. So you really need to compare the area where the tumor was injected,
which is here, to the contralateral hemisphere.
And you can see again that the color distribution is not random.
Anything that is on the other side of the brain tends to be
enriched in this bluish-like color, and these are, again, these
OPC/NPC-like cells, whereas the primary site is enriched in
different states. And again, in the paper, we develop how perivascular
invasion programs actually differ from periaxonal invasion programs and
how these different states that we captured by single-cell RNA sequencing actually
recapitulate different functions in the tumor and allow the tumor to expand into
different niches.As always, I have too many slides, so I
have to stop here because I don't want to be the one running above time
after telling everyone to stay on time.
So, just a vignette to say that we're doing similar efforts in IDH mutant
gliomas,
both single-cell analysis and spatial.
These papers are at various press of production.
And again, a lot of work from Masashi Nomura, who's in the room if you want to
discuss with him. I can give you maybe the take-home message from the IDH
mutant progression work that is in press, where we've actually
looked at the impact of changes in DNA methylation on the cell state hierarchy.
And what we found is that as methylation decreases, as this tumor advances,
which is a known phenomenon, we see that that affects the heritability of cell
states. We see change in differentiation trajectories and fewer
cells actually achieve differentiation.
More cells remain in stem-like programs.
The cell for neural stem cell is enhanced, and so we better understand now the
impact of hypomethylation on how hypomethylation is actually
really bad for clinical outcome, and maybe that's through changes in hierarchy.
And I frequently think that we're too obsessed with cell states, and
maybe it doesn't matter that much if you want to just try to get a
clinical handle on these tumors. But actually, when we analyze samples of
gliomas that respond to the current standard of care, targeted
therapy against IDH mutation, we see that those
agents actually affect these differentiation hierarchies.
Those agents actually do facilitate the differentiation of cancer cells.
That's probably how the clinical benefit is obtained.
And if you see that hypomethylation affect the capacity of cells to differentiate,
you might imagine that you might need to begin to integrate that into
stratification of patients, because we know that too few patients actually
respond to these therapies, and the field is trying to understand who will respond
and who will not respond. With that, I'm done.
I've already thanked the people along the way, so I'll stop here and thank you for
your attention and for staying to this session.
Yeah, fantastic work. Kind of just a question regarding the last part of your
study, the IDH mutant inhibitor and single-cell
analysis. Kind of curious, so from your analysis, did you
see that low-grade oligo or low-grade
astrocytoma, if both can respond to the treatment?
Did you see that there some difference in terms of differentiation?
So-
Or methylation, yeah.
Yeah.
The study actually focused a lot on oligodendrogliomas
in the response to targeted agent, because that's where we had enough
power to see
the signal. We had the challenge, and
this is more of a comment in general for the field, the challenge is that you will
see an effect of those agents if you sample and analyze on drug.
So you need to really get the sample while the patient is still receiving the drug-
Mm.
... and then do all this analysis, and you will see this effect of differentiation.
Anytime we've analyzed gliomas, even if they had a clinical response, but then for
some reason the patient stopped taking the drug, we can't see anything.
Mm.
So in our cohort, unfortunately, the astrocytomas were not so rarely
off drug, so it wasn't really conclusive.
And so we made more points about the oligodendroglioma.
But if you look at the Mellinghoff paper and they have some bulk analysis, if you
analyze that for the responders, it would seem that the signature that we detect by
single cell, you would expect to see it in astrocytoma as well.
And if you look at the breakdown of patients that respond to the targeted agent, it
does seem to affect both populations.
So whether you have an oligo or an astro, you should be able to respond.
Thank you.
With the risk of monopolizing this microphone, it's a really, really great talk.
I just wanted to get a clarification around the evolutionary trees when you
correlated that with the OPC-like state.
Would that then go essentially sort of against
that idea that OPC-like state is the sort of initiating state?
So when you start talking about the cell of origin, would that sort of, kind of
disprove that?
No, I don't think that, because, again, here we're analyzing very established and
advanced tumors, so it's very difficult to make any claim about how it started.
And also we can only
say something about what we see. It's unclear that we capture the inception of the
tumor. What I would say is that this tells us how it's evolving.
Mm.
And so at least in a few instances, the evolution doesn't seem to
be all the random states evolving.
It seems to be driven specifically by a subset of cells.
But
I'm pretty sure it won't be always these cells that are so aggressively evolving
the tumor, but we certainly see that in some cases it's not completely random.
And so-
Mm.
... it's complex questions, but I do think that we should be very careful
about making any claims about origin of the tumors we're analyzing, established
tumors.
For sure. Thanks.
Hi. I was curious about the OPC-like dissemination.
Are there any therapeutic strategies that you think would impact
OPC-like dissemination or differentiation to prevent this
state?
That's a great question. Probably Varun can answer better than I can.
I
do think that if we want to block that migration, it's really a neurodevelopmental
program that we need to target.
We don't put enough effort into that, but I do think that it's quite clear
now that this is the distally invasive state.
And so,
we're still
working very hard to dissect all the molecular features.
I can tell you from another spatial study that we're doing that
we see that that state also has importance to traverse the gray-white
junction. The paper is in bioRxiv.
It seems to be even a functional
barrier to go between the subcortical white matter and the
cortex,
and that might actually relate to the preferential location of
oligodendroglioma versus astrocytoma.
So there's still a lot to disentangle, and we're not thinking
about it enough therapeutically, but obviously that's the goal at some point, but
we haven't really developed a strategy.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Hi.
Last question.
Great studies. I was wondering about the layered and not
layered tumors organization. You had this study in
glioblastoma a couple of years ago-Last year, I
think the Filbin lab looked at it in pediatric ependymomas, and now
you mentioned also IDH mutant astrocytomas.
So I was wondering whether you think this sort of layering that you
see, and you can link it with other patient outcomes or phenotypes, whether
this is something recurrent on all the brain tumors or
it's something on IDH mutant or specifically iomas?
Yeah, no, I do think that you know a lot of the organizational principle will be
shared by different classes of brain tumors.
I think they all have to deal with the brain architecture.
They all have to deal with
stressors like hypoxia and necrosis.
So I think a lot of the response, and because of the kind of cellular elements
are shared, so it's easy to imagine that a lot of this architecture will be
similar. But it's only
organized to the extent that there are pressures to organize it.
So,
early on when it's like a
kind of initiating tumor, it's highly structured because of the
underlying anatomy of the brain.
As they break down the residual brain anatomy,
it becomes quite messy and very intertwined and not very
organized. And it's only later when you have really
important environmental pressure because they're beginning to run out of
nutrients-
Mm
... that you begin to see another pattern of organization.
So I don't think it's like, you know throughout the history of the tumor, it will
always be following a very precise organization.
It's just, at the beginning and as the necrosis occurs, these are
very important therapeutic kind of environmental pressures.
And then throughout, a lot of different scenarios can occur.
Have you looked also at primary recurrent tumors?
What's the difference in terms of these layerings?
So not spatially.
Okay.
But, again, in terms of cell state distribution, we've done quite a
lot of work in terms of how they evolve in primary and recurrence.
And the take home message is that
it's frequently different between the primary and recurrence, but it's different in
ways that most of the time we cannot really predict.
Mm.
And so again, there might be a lot of spatial confounders in how these
patients are sampled.
Okay, thank you so much.
Thank you.
All right. I'm one minute over time, so thank you all for staying.
Thank you for your attention. Thanks all the speakers again.